-My first guest is a
Grammy-winning artist
who has a
new documentary coming out
this Friday on
Amazon Prime Video called
"P!nk: All I Know So Far."
Please welcome
the one-and-only P!nk!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Ah! It's so good to see you.
Hi, bud!
-Hi!
-Oh, I love you.
Aww! Thanks for the hug.
I love it.
You know, we were talking about
you pretty recently,
because we had
Steve Buscemi on the show,
and he was explain--
He told me some story
that sounded pretty insane.
This is --
When you first started out,
you ran up to him,
'cause, obviously, he was
Mr. Pink in "Reservoir Dogs."
And he said he thinks you came
up to him and said like,
"You don't understand,
but I'm named after you,
and I'm going to be
big one day."
Or something.
He was freaking out about buying
a gift or something for --
He had a big, long story,
but he was so embarrassed.
And he thinks it was you,
and he never got
a chance to apologize to you.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
And is this a real story?
-Oh, I -- No, it's a real story.
But to be fair, I ran at him
on a New York street.
I physically -- I'm like
a hummingbird with my love.
I'm very aggressive.
-Okay.
-And I was just this pink --
I remember I was
dressed in, like, all --
a silver ensemble
and I had short, pink hair
and a tongue ring.
And I just --
"You're Steve Buscemi
and you're Mr. Pink
and I'm P!nk and you're pink
and I'm going to be so famous
and I just love you
and then I got my --"
And he's like, "What the [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
He was like, "Aah!"
I would have reacted
that way, too.
It was a lot.
-That's so funny.
And you haven't seen
each other since?
-No. I mean, All this time,
for like 20 years,
I was like, "That guy hates me."
-Oh, my gosh.
Well, anyway, he was embarrassed
and he was like --
because, obviously,
we know who you are now.
If you don't,
you're living under a rock.
This weekend --
You have a huge weekend.
You're getting the Icon Award
at the Billboard...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...at the
Billboard Music Awards.
Just don't listen for a second.
I just want to let
everyone know who else --
This has only been
given out 10 times.
Here's the people on the list.
Celine Dion, Mariah Carey, Cher,
Janet Jackson, Garth Brooks,
Jennifer Lopez,
Stevie Wonder, and Prince.
[ Cheers and applause ]
P!nk!
-That's a lot of pressure.
At first, I was like,
"Oh, it's the old-lady award.
I'm getting the old-lady award.
They want me to go."
-No, it's unbelievable.
-But, no, it's amazing!
I read the names, I was like,
"They got this wrong.
There's so many other names
that should be there."
-No.
-It's a huge honor.
And anytime they give me
eight minutes to perform,
I'm like, "Oh, it's on."
-Yeah.
-So, I'm very, very --
I'm probably looking forward to
this performance more than
I have looked forward to one
in a very long time.
I'm very nervous.
-I don't know how many people
come up to me and say like,
"Have you ever seen P!nk live?"
And I go, "Yeah."
And they go, "It's the best
concert I've ever been to.
It's amazing."
-Aww! That makes me so happy.
I'm terrible at a lot of things,
but I can perform.
-Yeah, you can. That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's exactly correct.
And I love this, by the way.
"P!nk: All I Know So Far:
SetList,"
your first-ever live album.
I love the name.
-Yeah, thank you.
-You never wanted to do
a live album.
-Nope. I never wanted to do
a documentary either,
but here we are.
-Well, I'm glad you did,
because now you're on the show.
This is fantastic.
Gives us something
to talk about.
But, yeah --
-I just miss --
I miss live music.
And it's just --
I think we all do.
I miss sweating with strangers.
And I listened to this set list
all the way through
and I just felt
so good at the end.
I think a lot of people --
still, after 20 years,
think I'm just this man-hating,
obnoxious, loud --
"So what?! Rah!"
But we do so many fun covers
and so many genres of music.
And there's Queen covers
and "Time After Time."
And I just felt really happy.
One of the --
We do "We Are the Champions"
at Rock in Rio in Brazil,
and I was just
instantly back there
with 100,000 people
sweating and happy.
And it just makes me feel good.
The record makes me feel good.
-P!nk, who directed this, again?
-Michael Gracey, from
"The Greatest Showman."
-Yeah. Michael Gracey,
"Greatest Showman."
Amazing director.
And I think, if I were you,
I would be like,
"Document everything,"
because you put on these shows
that are like "Whew!"
Do you get a chance to ever
look at your work
and you're like,
"Oh, yeah, I did that.
That was pretty cool."
-Yeah, I don't experience
things in real time.
It takes me a while.
I look back
and then I'm like, "Oh, wow.
Like, I hung from the side
of a building.
Why?"
But with this --
with this documentary,
I was like, You know what?
As kids, you narrate your life
and you tell these stories,
like, about your childhood,
and everybody had a terrible
childhood in some way.
And "My mom locked me in a
closet, I'm sure of it,
and I was never fed."
And so whatever stories
my kids come up with about me,
this documentary will prove that
they're not telling the truth.
-That's the whole reason
for doing this.
So that they can see mommy
was always loving
and gave you a great life.
-That's it.
-See? You need that, yeah.
So, yeah, lawyer up.
That's fantastic.
We love you.
I want to show everyone a clip.
-Here's P!nk
in her new documentary,
"All I Know So Far" --
Amazon Prime Video.
Take a look.
♪♪
-They grew up with
the hotels and the jets
and the never having to
worry about things
like money and safety.
And I'm their mom, I'm their
friend, but one day --
you know, one day, they're going
to see through all of it.
They're going to see the act.
They're going to see
through the strength
and they're going to find
the truth underneath, I hope.
And they're going to
discover little Alecia,
who's still hiding in here,
who's still learning
how to heal.
And I just hope they have
the grace and the heart
to accept my mortality
and to accept that I'm human,
like them.
And then they'll have
their own kids,
and so the cycle continues,
all of it.
-Flying through Wembley.
Flying through Wembley.
So cool.
P!nk, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]